hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to why do
we like to scare the shit out of our
kids in particular I'm talking about
kids movies yeah we got a lot of things
that are bright bubbly and don't have
anything the least bit threatening in
them but then we have movies like return
to odds
Coraline decision
Matilda good little Brucie can appear
key and of course a countless amount
from several Disney animated features
yeah some of these films have warranted
PG ratings but others mostly in Disney's
case still seem to get away with a G
rating meaning scenes like this or this
has been deemed child-friendly for boys
and girls of all ages bullshit this book
scares me even now so why are so many
scary moments not shied away from in so
many kids films isn't the idea of
showing your kids a movie either to
educate or just keep them happily
entertained for a bit seems like these
most kids would either cry or piss their
pants at so why are they in so many
family movies and more importantly how
come we're really not that bothered by
it
going way back to the famous Grimm's
fairy tales most stories intended for
children seem to focus on the extreme
dark and the extreme violent yeah when
you read the original Red Riding Hood or
Hansel and Gretel you'll find they're
pretty fucked up but at the very least
they'll be in kind of a twisted way they
were used to scare many kids into
remembering whatever life lesson it was
trying to teach don't trust strangers
don't be too selfish etc so scaring kids
to get a point across isn't anything new
well some claim that Disney's renditions
of these fairy tales is what sucked out
the harshness from future tellings of it
still take a look at some of this
imagery from say Snow White the first
animated feature
this is still pretty intense for little
kids and like I said before Disney has
never been a company to shy away from
the scary moments but what makes these
moments even stranger than something
like Grimm's fairy tales is that feats
aren't used to teach kids any lessons
they're usually there just to emphasize
how threatening the villains are or how
frightening the world can be hell in
some kids movies even that's not needed
I still don't know what the purpose of
that freaky tamo from Willy Wonka was
all about but director said it was just
to give a hint that there was something
kind of often creepy about the Chocolate
Factory are the fires of hell of glowing
this isn't a hint this is a fucking
jackhammer of Terror here hey
Vanina then the truth is you can get
across fear to a child with very little
because they're so young it doesn't take
that much to intimidate them yet so many
films go to such extremes to make sure
you don't forget the frightening moments
even if it's not teaching anything and
the rest of the movie is completely
upbeat and friendly so why have him in
there well I started to think back to
when I was little watching some of these
scary scenes everyone said well I hit
something that was a little too intense
for me but to be fair that was usually a
pg-13 or R rated movie but the
quote-unquote family-friendly shit your
pants moments I found I was scared by
but I still kept watching them not only
that I found I watched them a lot
I loved Return to Oz as a kid I adored
the Headless Horseman
I really enjoyed those creepy Disney
moments I vote dreaded and look forward
to at the same time never once did I
ever turn off the TV so I started to ask
myself what did I like about them I
found there were three things I felt
when watching those moments one was an
adrenaline rush kids like to be excited
that's why they imagine adventures to go
on a new dangers to go up against it's
thrilling and fun it's all part of being
a kid and putting yourself in those
extreme dangers leads me to the second
emotion I felt hope we're always used to
seeing the heroes in great peril and the
greater the peril the more you want to
see the hero get out of it and the more
menacing and scary the things the main
character has to go through are the more
you'll appreciate the happy ending that
most kids films deliver you can see this
a lot in many Don Bluth movies it was
rumored that he used to say you can show
anything to a child as long as it has a
happy ending
and oddly enough I think there is some
truth to that an American tale for
example has a lot of scary imagery and a
lot of intense moments in fact it's the
majority of the friggin movie but by god
doesn't it feel so good at the end when
it's all over isn't that family
reuniting just the most joyful thing you
ever saw after being put through so much
hardship but the secret to making that
work is balancing the scares out and
sometimes too many dark moments can work
against the movies intention
Disney's Christmas Carol with Jim Carrey
well not an awful movie relish is so
much in the dark moments that it often
forgets to let us enjoy the happy ones
Christmas Carol is a dark story but it
balances out with plenty of scenes
relishing in the joyful spirit of
humanity here the dark moments are so
heavy that the joyful moments are almost
glanced over so it just turns into
overkill now something like Coraline
oddly enough balances it out better
because despite the characters certainly
having her selfish moments we can see
what a good hearted soul she is and how
much she loves her family and what they
mean to her and on top of that there are
plenty of upbeat whimsical moments too
so even though it has many scary
elements it still delivers a pleasant
but also intense experience even fifl
and americantale he's a very simple
positive upbeat character he's the one
you follow and pulls you through all
these tough scary things you have to get
by and I guess that brings me to the
final emotion I felt whenever I watched
a scary moment as a kid the appreciation
of being challenged we're never gonna
run out of bright simplistic stuff for
kids it's all over the place
and with good reason we want to see our
kids live happy and optimistic lives
blah blah blah blah blah but when
something does come along that's
different or even a little threatening
there is kind of this intrigue as a kid
you ask yourself why is it secret of
NIMH talking to me like how Barney talks
to me why isn't ParaNorman talking to me
the same way Dora the Explorer talks to
me I think there's definitely times
whether kids realize it or not when they
want something more dangerous and even
questioning put in front of them kids
know there's things they're not going to
understand early in life that's why they
ask their parents so many things they
ask because there's a curiosity to find
out about them and oftentimes we forget
it's an emotional journey these aren't
the same challenges that love learning
programs are putting forward like
learning letters or numbers it's
challenging kids with feelings that
they've possibly never felt before and
bringing those feelings into their
awareness if anything they show it's
alright to be afraid that's a normal
part of life and the more you can
understand it or even confront it the
better off you'll probably be now does
this mean every kid should see something
as intense
or alive oh it depends on the kid every
kid is going to be afraid of something
different and is gonna deal with it at
their own pace what a certain
three-year-old could watch with great
excitement a certain seven-year-old
could still be closing their eyes at
it's like rollercoasters you can usually
tell by looking at them which one you
can probably handle and which one you
probably can't but you're still given
that option of subjecting yourself to
that fear you know what gives you two
grades can of course help out their
children discovering what they're ready
to take on and what they're not but it's
important to teach that being afraid is
not something to be ashamed of scary
moments are just another part of life
and how we deal with them is very very
important
scares are healthy for children as long
as it's in moderation they can be used
to challenge educate and even strengthen
if we choose to keep all the fears and
threatening things away from our kids
they'll never understand how the world
works so little scenes like this dropped
in every once in a while if carefully
done I think are actually very welcomed
additions they force kids to question
without being paranoid allowing them to
be cautious without being terrified
making them realize that there are scary
things in the world but there's also a
lot of good things too so as long as
frightening moments is being done for
one of those reasons I personally say
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
scaring the shit out of your kids
especially if we all know that these
things are not gonna scare us years
later I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember
you